ist es endlich soweit heute ist es
endlich soweit mir wurde erzählt leute
dass ein neues video von katja online
sein soll und dieses video heißt sex
tape ich glaube wenn wir ganz ehrlich
miteinander sind leute dann ist ein sex
tape von katja somit das was in youtube
deutschland aber allermeisten erwartet
wird aber in diesem fall ist das nun
musikvideo ist aber wir werden uns heute
mal anschauen sex tape music video das
nächste video von katja direkt nach blut
spritzt
aber warum sollte ich gehen heute wir
starten direkt war ein metzger ob es für
einen moment so aus wer die wirklich
nackt nackt in dem video
acht schüler die rewe einkaufstüten hat
sie sich etwas angehängt
[Musik]
mit diesem screenshot lachmann künstler
war niedrig was wir gerade machen das
ist 2018 in tag im august und das
einfach was gerade so auf youtube
passiert ja jetzt siehst du nicht über
den straßenverkehr gefährdet hallo man
muss es an der stelle einfach sagen
leute an diesem video ist musikalisch
und auch vom bild her und den textlichen
inhalte überhaupt nicht falsch aber was
nicht klar geht ist dass die mitten am
tag auf einer straße lang läuft und hier
den straßenverkehr in dieser form
erheblich behindert ich weiß nicht die
autos fall einer vorwahl wundere mich
dass keinen unfall gebaut hat er mache
doch mal eins aber ich glaube ganz
ehrlich leute bei so katja videos kann
man eigentlich nicht viel zu inhalt und
musik an sich seien also die musik ist
so standard xy male beat oder sonstwas
und der inhalt ist eigentlich auch
relativ klar deswegen muss man so ein
bisschen mehr außenrum kommentieren ich
glaube ganz ehrlich lasst uns mal eine
theorie aufstellt stellt euch mal vor
katja würde wirklich so ein sextape
veröffentlichen ich glaube das würde ihr
erst relativ viele aufmerksamkeit geben
und dann wäre ihre karriere auf youtube
vorbei ins sind vorbei aber ich habe
meine kommentare was ihr davon haltet
so könnt ihr achtung da hinten
kompletten roller katja gehst du bitte
von der straße runter
nein herr 6 11 nein-stimmen dass er den
hans entertainment 2 ist wieder da klar
wenn ich dich dann kleine rote ich habe
jetzt passiert nichts spannendes mörder
okay was passiert hier sie liegt im 108
es muss jetzt über die straße auch das
ist youtube leute auch das youtube ganz
ehrlich es ist ein bisschen witzig
bisschen unterhaltsames aber man könnte
eigentlich so katja videos einfach mit
nur eine einbildung ersetzen und die
dann auf drei minuten vier strecken und
zwar diese okay dann schmeißt den armen
typen noch irgendwie in brunnenbecken
ansteht weil mein bett in der pampa ich
ich muss wirklich los leute ich muss los
aber mal ganz dringend was soll man dazu
sagen leute wir haben das video
angeschaut und eigentlich würde man
denken dass man danach irgendwie ein
bisschen schlauer ist aber was
dazugelernt hat
aber ich bin eigentlich nur verwirrter
spaß kann ich liebe dich